voyez votre façade vous vous dites quoi
je me dis qu'elle est belle j'espère que
ça donnera envie à beaucoup de gens de
faire la même chose au numéro 8 de la
rue de la croix de bois dans le quartier
des carmes marie solange petit et la
millième propriétaire avoir rénové sa
façade avant sa maison ressemblait à ça
alors ça c'est ça la façade initiale
celle qu'elle avait dû être
vraisemblablement crépy dans les années
50 capes estime angie sont beaucoup de
caractère à orléans la rénovation des
façades a commencé il ya maintenant
quinze ans c'est surtout le centre
historique qui en a bénéficié
une campagne d'embellissement qui a
sacrément porté ses fruits on sait très
bien qu'un espace public qui est propre
qualitatif entraîne tout un ensemble
d'attitudes sociale plus ouverte plus
plus respectueux une fierté tout
simplement un plaisir pour le touriste
et on prendra comme exemple tous et au
relais à des qit maintenant des tests
laisser une crotte de leur chien sur le
pavé c'est ici au 25 rue de la
charpenterie que le plus vieux pans de
bois du centre ville a été repéré il
date de 1394 lui aussi a été
complètement rénové et si la couleur
rouge a été choisi pour ce pan de bois
ça n'est pas par hasard ce sont des
éléments qui sont trouvés conserver des
traces
et naturellement il convient de savoir
cette couleur à quelle époque elle
correspond et puis si on souhaite
restaurer à cette période là eh bien on
va mettre la couleur naturellement qui
existaient et qu'on a trouvé sur la
façade et donc il n'ya pas de
subjectivité 1 c'est la façade qui nous
donne ce rouge ce jaune ce bras pour
chaque propriétaire le coût de la
rénovation s'élève en moyenne à 30000
euros
ils ont pu bénéficier d'une subvention
de la ville à hauteur de 30%
autre grand gagnant les entreprises du
secteur qui ont généré en tout près de
40 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires